brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment it's that time again to
talk to you about the latest games in
new releases and this week the sci fi
space exploration game Sid Meier's
starships launches onto pc mac and ipad
this game takes place in the same
fictional universe as beyond Earth but
don't get confused this is not beyond
Earth two but its own space Beast you
take command of an entire fleet of
powerful starships to travel between
planets exploring building negotiating
and eventually killing to preserve your
vision for the future of humanity your
adventure begins on the 12 also this
week the acclaimed Ori and the blind
forest makes its debut on PC and Xbox
one you're a glowing guardian spirit
raised by a sweet bear-like creature now
exploring a dark forest it's like
Princess Mononoke and ferngully in an
interactive Wonderland save points are
called soul links and you can make them
anywhere you please but they require a
particular amount of materials found in
the forest which means you have to
choose when you want to make the
checkpoint become kodama on the 11th
also this week the third part of
resident evil revelations 2 comes out to
give you a few more pieces of the Barry
Burton puzzle but you'll have to hold on
until part 4 for that ultimate reveal I
don't want to give away too much so just
look out for Moira on the 11th moving on
to a few re-releases Sniper Elite 3
ultimate edition comes to last and
current PlayStation and Xbox three
additional single-player missions six
additional weapon packs and 18 new
weapons have been added
also Devil May Cry definitive edition
comes in with 1080p graphics at 60
frames per second if you've never bought
either of these games before this is a
really good time to pick them up and
they both drop on the 10th this week we
get a game for SimCity fans that might
not have gotten everything they wanted
from the latest installment city
skylines arrives on PC to bring scale
and interest to urban simulation crafter
City as you see fit adding curved roads
cramped condos and as many bars there
are starbucks in real life ensure proper
flow of electricity and water deal with
crime pollution and even track citizens
and animals for that feeling of sheer
power there's too much to list in this
short amount of time so if this looks
right up your alley you can get more
info on steam and it releases on the
10th finally hotline Miami 2 wrong
number is finally being released you can
vent out all your frustrations to sick
new beats screw trilogy's because this
sequel will conclude the original story
of intense violence and retribution and
it even adds a dual wielding option for
maximum blood the savage brutality is
all beautifully set to another fantastic
soundtrack that you can enjoy in game or
any other moment of your non murderous
life put on your mask on the 10th for
further details visit gamespot com where
these dates are based on retail listings
and are subject to change see you next
week